do you want no one leaves 90 troll
everybody miss my dad hamdulillah
assalamu alaikum those are the greetings
of peace peace be unto you thank you for
turning into the Dean show and today
we've had James James who accepted Islam
a few years back Islam which simply
means surrender peace acquired by
surrendering your will yourself to the
one God the creator of the heavens and
earth so he accepted this beautiful way
of life the way of life of all the
messages of God just to name a few
Abraham Noah Moses Jesus Christ and the
last and final messenger sent to mankind
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
all he's going to be talking to us a
little bit about his experience now now
he's a Muslim is it easy ride is are
there some obstacles how's it been we
want to follow up so when we come back
we'll be talking to James here on the
Dean show will be right back Allah
there's only one
is his messenger Allah Allah Allah
there's only one where Jesus was his
messenger Allah no I did that maybe it
maybe it's just to break the ice
assalamo alaikum brother welcome salam
peace be with you sent to you bro how
are you been on the law because some of
the viewers of the Dean show who have
been following us for some time they got
to see the show we did a few years back
and for those that didn't get a chance
to see those shows we're going to start
off by kind of recapping how you
actually came to Islam give us the gist
of it talk to us ok the gist of it well
before before I came back to Islam was a
practicing Christian I could say you
know doing it you know the things that
Christians do going to church and
reading the Bible and actually I had a
brief conversation with you with that
started it out mom as you remember and
that that conversation led me to do
research on my own and then that led to
more conversations between us and
shortly after I accepted Islam so were
you before Islam were you live in just a
normal life were you just going about
you know your business going to school
or work and just family what were you
doing at the time I had I had just just
got married I was working I already
started my career and everything so
everything and my life was starting to
come together I should say everything
was going good but it was still
something that was that was that was
missing something that wasn't complete
and and i think i found that thing when
i accepted Islam now a lot of people
they know that something's missing
there's an incomplete faction in their
life and now many of them don't come to
that state they fill it with other
material things maybe they get busy in
relationships work money but now what
made
you go beyond try and send those limits
and know that no it has to be something
more than just the material things um
because I've always been a believer in
knowing that there is something deeper
than just material things I mean because
money can come and go you can make money
and you can lose money some people can
come and go but there is one thing that
always there and that's a lot and most
of the time people don't realize it but
they go to a lot when they're they're in
trouble or when they have problems in
that family or other things like that
but you have to remember even even the
good times a law is always there the bad
times a law is always there throughout
your entire life whatever happens the
law is always there so that I think
that's something that I've always had in
my life even it's times i can remember
when i was when i was a child i don't
really talk about it much but certain
things happened in my life and always
thought and what would God want me to do
or it's God looking at me right now you
know things like that so you some people
just have to dig deeper and continue to
search you know when those are
superficial things when they feel like
they feel the void mm-hmm I think it
just is just a matter of time before
they get back to the same track boom
something's gotta eat something I need
something bigger I need something better
and it's just a matter of time and
hopefully they'll meet someone like like
me for example I met you and a lot of
other brothers that helped put me on the
right track you use the word Allah now
before accepting this way of life Islam
the way of life of all the messengers of
God did you call God by this name
obviously not what was the name you call
God before God you just said god yes and
what some people have to understand is
that the word God this is the English
word it's a word that that was made you
know here is an English word that if you
research and study and go back that you
see that God was never referred to the
creator of the heavens and the earth was
never really referred to as God he was
referred to as other terms and the terms
are closer to Allah yeah and I'm washing
research and studying you know you
figure out these things is
it's not hard to refer to the Creator as
with his true name as its true name so
this is not a moon God or some kind of
Arab god no no this is the creator of
the heavens and earth were talking that
created you me and everybody else you
know everything on the earth is not a
guy for one set group of people it is
the Creator created everybody everything
you see is from a lot I want to make one
note on that the Arab and Jewish
Christians they used the word Allah also
and it's in the Arabic Bible yeah where
Allah and when Jesus who spoke he didn't
speak English he spoke Aramaic but he
would say aloha that's Aramaic and see
and I think if you explain that specific
fact to a lot of Christians and a lot of
people from other religions religious
they'll come to they'll come to
understand or get closer to the truth
Jesus Christ I Lahey salata wassalam he
didn't speak English yeah you know he
was Jewish and he didn't say God you
know if you go back and study a little
bit you you'll see that you know this is
a word that was started here you know
it's an English word this is something
this is something new is not with the
beginning of the religion the religions
is this is something new that work so
now that you have accepted this way of
life Islam how do you feel now it has it
been challenging has it been easy has it
been something that has brought
tranquility and peace to your life how's
it been um I can actually talk about
this topic for a day two days yeah um
there have been ups and downs so far
when I went when I first accepted Islam
some friends and some family looked at
me as if I was doing something that was
you know totally out of the ordinary
totally just you know new but at the
same time I did have some friends and
some family that accepted it 100% yeah I
already think a lot had some family that
had already accepted Islam and some
friends that were Muslim and they helped
make the transition easy but throughout
these last few years I've had some
instances in my life where I used on the
teachings of the
profits on selling directly in my life
to help me I mean that's the thing about
Islam it's not just something that you
do on fridays or not just something you
do once or twice a day is it's an entire
way of life I mean every aspect of your
life work with your wife husband um just
every everything you have to deal with
in a day to day life Islam can't it's a
way an exact way to deal with things
it's a complete way of life complete
let's leave it there and we're going to
come back with more with our brother
James here on the Dean she'll be right
back is the mean he's did you say that
you're not believe in Jesus you have
stepped outside of his name you can not
be a Muslim is attended our faith to
believe in and love Jesus Christ by the
riches why is it then when it comes to
one of the most important decisions in
life he literally abuse ourselves it's
not that the main thing we're looking
for is to see what type of money he has
so that he can treat my daughter like a
princess it's not about
back with our brother James so we left
off with you accepting Islam and then
you had some instances with your family
or friends family friends yes yeah and
but was it and you mentioned something
really key that Islam is not something
you do part times not something you do
just on Fridays and Sundays but let's
back it up a little bit when you were
practicing Christianity is this
something that how did it compare to
this way of life now did you just do
that part time or what was something
what was the deficiency there what was
something that was missing there that
you had to make this transition okay the
difference a lot of people say you know
you can't judge a religion by the people
yeah and it's a lot it's a lot of truth
in that mm-hmm but I noticed in
Christianity I practice I went to church
and I was following the teachings of the
religion yeah but there were some things
that came into question as far as i'll
give you one instance mm-hmm i went to
church one Sunday and I actually me and
a friend we went to church and we you
know I had my own Bible he had a Bible
and the preacher he started the sermon
and he started to preach but then he
said refer to your Bible and he said
refer to this Bible but you can't refer
to that Bible yeah so you say for
example you could refer to the the King
James Version but not the new
international version so i was confused
at why is it two different Bibles what
is he what is the problem why is it like
that him and not only that it's just
some things that um some people did
there were I don't I couldn't see how
they could consider themselves spiritual
or religious people when they will leave
one institution and leave the
institution and go do things that that
contradict the religion or contradicts a
person that believes in the Almighty so
you were seeing things that it just
didn't fit with would you say this
natural disposition that's inside of us
you know when you just know something's
right or something's wrong is embedded
in all of us I can give you an example
and in the Bible there are a few
versus that refer to just like in the
crime they refer to what you can and
can't eat yeah and it's a pretty regular
occurrence where people who are
Christians they don't follow them they
don't follow the Bible and I know I've
seen it myself they do the exact
opposite now if the book that you follow
in a religion that you follow tell you
to do one thing why would you do the
opposite it's not the case in Islam it's
that we have a set route we have set
rules and we follow the rules certain
things that we we should not do when
certain things we should do and we
fought try to follow those things to the
utmost so we got both now we got the
letter of the law and the spirit of the
law so it's an equal balance right you
can't just pick things like a buffet say
aha I'll do this one day throw this out
and whatever is convenient for me
basically none you doing your own things
right and a lot of people do that yeah
I'm with Islam it's not like that I mean
you you have to take the religion as it
is as God told you to take as God told
you to do is just as he told you to do
and he gives you the outline exactly
what you need to do when you need to do
it how you need to do it so there'll be
no problems there'll be no problem now
did you have a like we do anyone who
studies Islam knows that we as Muslims
over 1.5 billion of us if we don't
accept Jesus peace be upon him as a
mighty messenger of god we're not Muslim
right we say peace be upon him when you
say his name how did you feel when you
entered Islam did you feel now
disconnected from Jesus did you feel was
this a hard thing to give up what was
your relationship with Jesus before and
now the my relationship with Jesus
alayhi salat the westland before was I
love before yet confusion because of
what was taught in the church yeah in
the church they teach three mm-hmm Jesus
Christ alayhi salat the westerly o Allah
and the Holy Ghost and they teach that
they're all one yeah which is very
confusing yeah to anyone but if you
really really look at Islam it teaches
there's one guy one guy one guy and all
the prophets
he sent yes line of prophets mm-hmm line
of prophets long line so all you have to
do is worship the One God yeah listen
the prophets listen to the prophets try
to emulate the prophets try to be like
the prophets the way they worship the LA
and you'll be on the right path and my
relationship with with Jesus alayhi
salam it's better now because I I no
fully understand who he who he is we was
what he was sent for man and his message
and as we as Muslims we believe in in
Jesus alayhi salam and I feel that we
follow Jesus better than a lot of
Christians do mm-hmm no no this is a you
know we love our brothers in humanity
and our intention is always just to
educate to proliferate the tree and I
don't mean to disrespect anyone not to
say anything wrong towards any religion
because we as Muslims we we give respect
to every religion we don't disrespect
any religion not not one bit yeah even
if some people have some things toward
Muslims you know that's your own belief
but we don't disrespect anyone religion
not not at all that's one thing if you
believe in Allah you respect people and
you treat people the way you want to be
treated so I don't mean to say anything
wrong towards any religion you know now
tell us did you have because a lot of
people to have an experience they see
someone in a dream something comes to
him and now they feel like the person
was let's say on drugs I'm cracker this
person was just having the worst time of
his life he she whoever and now they say
that something came upon them they had
this revelation that had his experience
was that what led you to Islam or was it
something more intellectual talk to us
about this um I think it was it first of
all let me just start from the beginning
I think like I said before as a lot
makes us all the same way and he put
something in his where you believe you
do believe in the Creator but some
people let outside things deter them or
make them think a certain way but if you
keep with that honest belief inside and
you go straight you'll find the way it
was I had no Big Bang
revelation on my own and nothing like
that i just kept that feeling inside
that man you know I know it's one God I
know its one guy and I just stayed with
that and as I got older you know like I
said I met you when I meant a lot of
other brothers research you can't just
go into something blindly mm-hmm you
have to study you have to get in and
read and see for yourself some people
they just go with something someone
might tell them this or that no just
follow that you can't do that you can't
do it you can't just go blindly you have
to see for yourself me being a person
that was not Muslim and now me being a
person i am a muslim i know i know for a
fact that I made the right choice
because I studied before and I study now
and I know that I made the right choice
so something intellectual and something
I went with your very nature no
confusion no ambiguity is straight clear
you know what the concept of light of
God is you know what the purpose of life
is no confusion no confusion at all no
everything's laid out how you need to
live from A to Z a tizzy a tizzy no
problem beautiful no guesswork no guess
or not at all yeah let's take a break
and we'll be right back with more with
James on the Dean shop you have to pray
as if everything depends on a lot and it
does but you must work everything
depends on you and it does that's my
point you see I'm same and I don't like
that I don't like us sitting here what
are you waiting for what are we waiting
for right now what are you waiting for
all these people to come to this nah
what are you waiting for what are we
waiting for right now when they're gonna
come they're gonna come along and bring
these people lots upon the water put in
our hand the ability to do it now do
your job
Oh
and we are back on the Dean show with my
brother and your brother James peace be
with you thank you for being with us
once again for Evan tell us now let's go
back to the current situation did you
have many people they they come to this
way of life is simple to understand
worship the One God the one who created
you who created Jesus who created the
son who created the moon that God the
one that jesus prayed to the one that
all the messages of God talked about the
One God right it's something that again
like you just mentioned it goes with
your very nature I want to worship that
one God not anything in the creation not
a man at the Sun at the moon but not an
elephant none of these things and I want
to follow the guidance that he sent
through the messengers and just like he
sent Jesus at that time as a messenger
and Moses at that time and Abraham at
that time he sent the last and final
message the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon us and we have the perfect example
we don't worship Muhammad but he is that
GPS on how to pray to God how to worship
God how to do things correctly the same
way Jesus peace be upon him was the way
the truth and the light at that time you
as far as i know you jumped in and you
started you got hooked up right away you
started the prayer you started fasting
some people procrastinate they accept
this where we talked about it's pretty
easy to comprehend if you just go with
what's in yourself already you use a
little bit of your comments em you're
courageous enough you do the right thing
but now we got bad habits you know we'll
get up for the Money in the dollar at a
certain time but when God Almighty tells
us to get up and pray we don't pray we
don't fast how could our brothers and
sisters of humanity accepted its life
overcome the obstacles with your
experience share with us so they can get
on track like many others have and stay
away from getting off track talk to us
well let me just say that there will
always be obstacles in life from the day
you're born to the day you die and the
one thing that I can just say is
throughout everything it's like a rope
and you just have to hold on to the Rope
of Allah if you hold on to that rope
faster that rope you'll be okay though
there'll be things that come up through
your life always hold on to the Rope of
Allah always and through that you
remember making salat fasting I mean
doing all the things you need to do
it'll make things it will make it a
little easier yeah a little easier and
times will come you may feel tired or
you may feel a little discouraged but
always hold on to that rope always hold
on to the rope just never let it go and
when you hold on to the rope it'll it'll
give you courage and through it courage
you start to study and started to read
and through all of this you can educate
yourself and you'll know that you know
there will be bad times and there'll be
good times but just continue to hold on
to that rope do you have what you didn't
have before do you have peace are you at
peace now do you have tranquility I have
well I've got a person I think always
had peace there were at me as a person I
had some deficiencies in myself as we
all do yeah but I think through Islam I
was able to work on some of those
deficiencies and now I'm a more humble
person more calm and I remember the
things that i read from the prophets
allah seven armed with something we have
called hadith in the summer which is
simply the way of the Prophet and I try
to follow those things and just try to
be humble I can never be like the
Prophet peace and blessings of Allah be
upon them but I try my best to try to
emulate them and just try to do those
things and just be humble just be humble
and hopefully in sha Allah allow make
away for has a law made it easier have
you ever had someone like you mentioned
family and some friends and someone you
know chocolate terrorists her someone
says something you know under his breath
for two you have you had this and how
did you overcome it appear just like
just like with anything in life they're
always always be someone that will be
there to say something negative but at
the same time there'll be someone there
to say something positive awesome so
what this is like I said it said before
it just hold on to the Rope of Allah
just saw it just always remember who's
the creator whose the final judge who
was the one that everything that it
matters to everything you do it matters
to a loss Panama tava everything you do
so just remember that and I think most
people it will
it'll be easier to stay on the right
track remember whose whose opinion
really counts so to speak the one who's
running the show that's right and we're
gonna have to go back to that's right
brother thank you very much they allowed
the creator of the heavens earth rewards
you and keep you steadfast thank you
very much thank you and that was our
brother and your brother james who came
on he was with us before but now you see
that the brother he stood with it he
didn't give up and that's the main thing
those who have acknowledged what's in
their very nature that there is a create
or design indicates a designer there is
one who is sustaining and maintaining
this whole universe and everything in it
and he is the most why so he didn't
create us for any foolish purpose and
his system that he sent through all the
messengers of God including the last and
final messenger that if we follow this
system the way of submitting yourself
acquiring peace by the total submission
to the One God that's it him he is the
one we're going to have to go back to
and we follow what he's told us to do
the letter of the law as they say the
rules and injunctions and the spirit of
the law we have a complete balance so
this is something that when we do it we
get that tranquility we get the peace
and there will be times that will be
tested but as our brother James give us
that good advice hold on to the rope and
never let go and at the end what it
really matters it comes down to is that
we please the one who created us and he
only calls us to good he only calls it
to that which will give us life in this
life and the hereafter so with that said
continue straight away don't stop you
can come back here every week to the
Dean show we also have the radio show
that we started at the Dean show com
blog section you can go on the TV if you
missed us on the TV you go to our
website where you can catch all of our
shows weekly they come on and you can
see the times that they're aired all
across the globe we'll see you next time
God willing until then peace be unto you
no speech is better than to do that
would call people to Allah and to do
there were no speeches better no
nothing is better than that is it true
that if one person I'm the Allah giving
you an ability to guide so much for the
lost permission the craters permission
that was better than everything in this
world but in the whole world and
everything that's in it in another
narration it's better than the best of
wealth but if we really felt that Eddie
would we not be giving out gettings out
and this is something that we encourage
all the msas all the dowel organizations
the mustards forget this we want to
trade more we give these to the non mrs.
for free for free for free we want our
brothers it's cold it's Leigh everybody
sleep in I arise and ask a lot of
thinking me Omar you see hola you know
all the sins I do I turn to you to
forgive my sin tomorrow I'm you seen for
slave you're my love alone I'm the one
runs away oh the guide me